Giovanni Julie vuelve al Cabildo de su
resguardo indígena de la etnia NASA está
en el municipio de caloto en el
suroccidente de Colombia Saludos abrazos
y compromisos ya Giovanni conoce el
proceso en lugar de un Regreso como
líder indígena ahora lo hace del otro
lado el tema de lo que nos corresponde a
nosotros como entidades el tema de la
restitución es el nuevo director de
restitución de tierras la agencia del
gobierno encargada de devolver las
hectáreas despojadas a las víctimas del
conflicto colombiano
ven en nosotros la esperanza de hacer
esos cambios estructurales de la
política del Estado y a la vez
preocupado porque por supuesto desde la
institucionalidad hay muchas
frustraciones es que llueve mucho allá
Giovanni ahora del frío de Bogotá la
capital antes del nombramiento siempre
estuvo en su territorio Allí se
convirtió en un importante líder del
cric uno de los principales movimientos
indígenas de Colombia la UNESCO maestro
de la sabiduría
entre múltiples compromisos ha vuelto
para presentarse como director ante su
gente
que todavía hay
que ha renacido la esperanza Colombia
sobre la expectativa es muy grande desde
la prensa local y hasta las comunidades
indígenas afrodescendientes y campesinas
Por fin se ven representados tras ser
nombrado por Gustavo Petro el primer
presidente de izquierdas de la historia
de Colombia debe ser es la ciudadanía la
gente organizada la que debe de
propiciar esos cambios
Giovanni Julie fue víctima del conflicto
el departamento del cauca es uno de los
más disputados hay numerosos cultivos de
coca y es un lugar de tránsito de
economías ilegales los indígenas quedan
en medio Tal vez es la primera vez en la
historia que nosotros podemos tener el
director de la unidad de restitución en
nuestro territorio que vamos a seguir
restituyendo la tierra para armonizar la
vida restitución de tierras entró en
funcionamiento en 2012 con la ley de
víctimas
10 años después solo se han restituido
un 10% de seis millones de hectáreas en
la próxima década deberán restituir un
90%